[Music]
hi everyone. Thank you for uh coming to
our talk. Uh so he was kind enough to
already introduce us. Um so I'm the CEO.
Matthew was the first person who joined
us. Uh if any difficult questions,
please direct it towards Matt. Um now if
you think about the three major
categories of of software engineering at
least as we see it there's three things
that show up to me the system design
where you think about you know how do
you actually architect a system a lot of
the the talks we saw in this uh track
have been about that in some sense at a
high level second is actually developing
software right putting in the business
logic of your particular company and and
all of the devops that comes with it and
then when you when your software
actually hits production invariably it's
going to break and then troubleshooting
of these production incidents right at
the heart of it those are the three
things interspersed with each other as
you think about developing production
grade software.
Now what what's been happening with the
magic of um AI software engineering
tools like cursor or winds or GitHub
copilot and there's many more others the
the part around development is getting
narrowed right that's the part we're
relying on all these different systems
to do it for us and increasingly so
right so over the next year I'd say more
and more of what we see uh is going to
make the development part of it really
seamless right the question is what
happens to the other two parts of this
entire software engineering workflow the
first one being system design and the
other one being troubleshooting Right
now, what is the promise that is u as we
think about what software engineering
could look like is that we'll get to
focus on just the most high impact and
creative work that happens in
engineering which is system design.
Right? So, we're hoping that AI will
write our code for us and also
troubleshoot all the production
incidents. So, we just get to focus on
the fun stuff which is the creative work
of how do we put all these different
pieces together. That's the hope. Um I
actually think that to make that happen
there's something missing right which is
the the problem of troubleshooting. How
do you automate that part of it? And I
think if we just continue in the way
we're going, it's actually going to look
the opposite is that most of our time I
think is going to be spent doing on call
for the m vast majority of us. And why
is that? I think troubleshooting is
going to get more and more complex as we
go along. Uh first is that as we write
as these software engineering AI
software engineering systems write more
and more of our code, humans are going
to have less context about what
happened. They don't understand the
inner workings of the code. They don't
have all the context in their minds.
Right? Second, we're going to push these
systems to the limit. So we're going to
write more and more complex systems just
like the things we saw in the previous
talks, right? Right? So the system's
going to get more complex and we're
going to have less understanding of it.
And as a result, troubleshooting is
going to get really really painful and
complex. And I think that's where we're
going to spend most of our time in this
world which is just QA and on call,
right? And that would be kind of a sad
existence for ourselves if that's what
happens, right? So this I think is a
grim reality if we don't do something
about it.
So now if you think about the workflow
of troubleshooting, what does it look
like? In my head, you'll have all of
these different wonderful companies like
Graphfana, Data Dog, Splunk, Elastic,
uh, Sentry, whatever it might be. And
what they do essentially is they help
process data and help you visualize it,
right? And so if anyone who's been on a
data dog dashboard or whatever it might
be, you have these beautiful dashboards,
thousands of them to give you some cut
as to what is the health of your system.
Now, something will break invariably in
production. Then what happens next? The
next step, as I see it, is what I call
dashboard dumpster diving, right? Right?
You'll go through all these different
thousands of dashboards to try to find
the one that explains what happened. And
you'll try to have many different people
doing it in parallel. At some point, you
might come up with some sort of
promising lead being like, okay, maybe
that was it. That's the dashboard that
kind of explains what happened or that's
the log that kind of explains what
happened. Then you want to connect it to
some sort of change you made in your
system, right? As we think about root
cause analysis, it's typically you're
trying to connect it to some particular
change in the system, whether it's a
pull request or a change of your
configuration files, whatever it might
be, right? Right? And that's where you
start say that's the second stage of
your troubleshooting which you stare
aggressively at your code base till
something you know some sort of uh
inspiration hits you and then most of
the time it doesn't hit you and then you
kind of bring more teams into the mix
because you know it's maybe not be your
issue and suddenly you have 30 40 50 100
people in a slack incident channel
trying to figure out what happened and
this loop keeps going on and on and on
right so the status quo of what incident
production incident debugging looks like
clearly is is not optimal and I think
it's only going to get worse based for
all the reasons I talked about earlier.
Okay? And obviously this problem has
been around since software has been
written and it's not like we're the
first people to think about thinking of
this issue. Right? The problem is that
the existing approaches we've taken to
troubleshooting or using machine
learning or AI towards it have not
worked and I don't believe will work for
really fundamental reasons. Right? So
the first one is what we call AI ops
broadly speaking which is we're using
traditional machine learning and
statistical anomaly detection type
techniques to help figure out what
happened. Right? The problem is if any
of you have actually tried these
techniques in production systems, it
leads to too many false positives. Your
system is too complex. It's too dynamic.
And if you just try to come up with some
sort of numerical representation of your
data, it's going to be not
representative enough. And what you'll
see is that you'll have thousands of
alerts happening. Maybe one of them is
useful, but you just don't know which
one, right? So typically leads to more
signal, sorry, more noise than signal is
what AI ops has led to sadly. Okay, now
we have this new world of LLMs. Okay, so
one option is okay, let me I'm sure many
people here have taken a log and put in
chat GPT and said explain to me what
happened what what's going on in this
log. Right? That's something I think all
of us have done. Now that's okay if you
know which log you want to look at. But
if I'm actually dealing with production
grade systems, you're going to have
terabytes of data. You might have a
trillion logs. Which one do I look at?
You can't take all of these different
logs, the trillion logs and put into
context. Right? Even if you have
infinite context, it doesn't matter. The
size of these systems are so large that
forget about context window. It doesn't
even fit into memory. It doesn't even
fit into a cluster. That's why you have
such difficult retention policies for
data, right, for logs and metrics. And
second, the problem with these LLMs are
is that they don't have a really good
understanding of the numerical
representation of the data. So they have
a good semantic understanding. They
don't have a good numerical
representation and also the context
isn't big enough. Okay. Now, the third
thing we might think about is let's
build an agent, right? Like let's build
a React style agent. The problem with
that is that if you think about these
React style agents, what they're going
to do is they're going to assume you
have some access to some sort of
runbook. Some sort of meta workflow that
they can rely on to help you make the
decision of what next tool to call. The
problem is any runbook you actually put
into place is deprecated the second you
create it. I don't know how many of you
have used runbooks, but typically what
we found in my experience and the team's
experience is that they're typically
deprecated by the time they're built,
right? And so that workflow that the
agent is going to go through is not
going to be um is is is just not going
to be optimal. And also if you try to
make it do a much more broad search of
your system, if you give it these simple
tools, it's going to be take too long,
right? If you just put it in into like a
loop tool to tool calling loop, it might
take days to run if if it doesn't time
out, right? And typically if you try to
solve an incident, you need to solve it
in two to five minutes for it to be
really useful, right? So every minute
counts when things are down. So as a
result, none of these three things if
you do them just by themselves is enough
to really d troubleshoot. There's
fundamental issues in all of them that I
think need to be solved by thinking
about them in a more collective way. And
that's really what we're trying to do at
tra traversal, right? What you need to
do with traversal is what we're trying
to do with traversal is really good out
of sample autonomous troubleshooting,
which is that you have a new incident,
we've never seen it before. Can you
troubleshoot it from first principles
debugging? And to do so, I think we need
to combine a few different ideas. The
first one being statistical, the second
one being semanticus and then the third
one being a novel agentic control flow.
And with statistics, what I mean is is
causal machine learning. So that's where
a lot of our research came. So the idea
of causal machine learning is this idea
of being correlation isn't causation. So
how do you get these AI systems to pick
up cause and effect relationships from
data programmatically? That's what we
spend a lot of time thinking about. And
obviously that problem shows up a lot in
production incidents because typically
when something breaks a lot of things
break around them, right? So there's a
lot of correlated failures which are not
the root cause. And so thinking about it
programmatically is what the study of
causal machine learning is. The second
being semantics, right? Which is
actually trying to push the limits of
what these reasoning models can give you
uh to help you understand the semantic
rich semantic context that exists in in
log fields in the metadata source of the
metric and so on so forth, right? Or in
code itself, right? And so by combining
causal machine learning, which is the
best of what statistics gives you, and
reasoning models, which is the best of
what semantics gives you, you now have
at least the tools, the basic tools to
put into place so that you can actually
deal with this issue. Now you have to
figure out how do you actually make this
work in an agentic system. And what we
found is this idea of swarms of agent
where you have these thousands of
parallel agentic tool calls happening
giving you this kind of exhaustive
search through all of your telemetry in
some sort of efficient way. That's what
brings it together and helps you
actually deal with this issue. Right? So
just to repeat it's statistics which is
causal machine learning semantics which
is these reasoning models and this novel
agentic control flow which you call the
swarms of agent. All of this put
together in the right elegant way is
what actually helps you autonomously
troubleshoot right and a lot of the work
we we rely on is based on our years of
research years of experience as
researchers. We've written a number of
papers on these various different fields
and also relying on a lot of the
research that has happened uh in general
in the field over the last couple of
years that we're relying on to actually
make this into a reality. Um and so if
you think about the the troubleshooting
workflow we talked about earlier and all
the pains of it, each of the different
things can help remove or alleviate some
of those pains. So the idea of finding
the promising lead from your sea of
information, that's where this agent
swarm and causal machine learning put
together really help. And then from the
promising lead connecting it to a
specific change in your system whether
it's a pull request or change log that's
a lot of the work that's happening in
code agents and also vector search
relying on it. Uh as this get better we
get better right and as a result because
you're building this context real time
and agents are doing it they're pulling
in the right team at the with the right
context or the right time and so don't
people want to get pulled into an
incident being like I don't really know
why I'm being pulled in here which I'm
sure many of you have been experienced
in your time as engineers. Um, and so
now I'm going to hand it over to Matt to
actually talk through a real life uh
case study uh that we've done with one
of our customers. Hi
everybody. I'm Matt as Anish said. Thank
you. Uh, and no, I I don't own any of
their outfits. Um,
so I'm going to tell you a little bit
about how I got involved with Traversal.
I'm going to show you how we are helping
out some of our customers. So, uh, in my
career I spent most my time in high
frequency trading. uh what I wanted to
spend my time doing there was uh you
know focusing and writing beautiful
code. What I ended up doing much more
often than not was debugging production
incidents. So I got sick of this as you
might understand and uh very happily
quit. Sometime later I I found myself in
a class on causal AI. Uh the guy
teaching the class seemed pretty smart.
it uh looking back then it may have just
been the fact that he was much better
dressed than your average computer
science professor and he had a you know
a fancy accent. Um but he uh he
mentioned in class one day sort of an
off-hand comment it seemed that oh you
might be able to use causal AI to
automate incident remediation workflows
and I'm sitting in the back back of the
class and my head explodes like this
sounds like an amazing idea and so I
casually come up to him at the end of
class and say you know maybe we might
want to do a research project on this
and uh little did I know that at the
time he had actually started a company
to solve this problem so he invited me
to join him on that journey and I'm very
grateful for that. And so fast forward a
year though and we have uh we built
something that we're quite proud of and
I'll I'll show you how it works. Uh but
to begin uh I'm going to be talking
about a client of ours, Digital Ocean.
Digital Ocean is a cloud provider. They
serve hundreds of thousands of customers
every day. And I'm going to tell you
about what uh the life of an on call
engineer was like prior to Traversal.
So, imagine you're in the middle of a
productive workday. You're focused day
in. You're writing code. Um, and then
you get hit with a message uh describing
something that's broken horribly. It's
it's causing issues for customers. It
might say something like powered some
potential compromise of some host
assigned to, you know, a bad
application. And my apologies in advance
here. This is not a demo per se. This is
us telling you in the real world how uh
we are we are solving issues for our
customers. So apologies for the
redactions that you're seeing here.
So you get this context and then you get
thrown into an incident Slack channel
and in this Slack channel you and 40 50
60 other engineers begin frantically
searching to find what's the cause of
the customer issue, right? But you're
not looking through some documents,
you're not looking through a database
table. You're looking through hundreds
of millions of metrics which are
viewable on thousands of dashboards.
And beyond this, you also have tens of
billions of logs that you might want to
find. And these are coming from
thousands of services. And what's the
thing you're looking for here? You're
looking for a something that's
comparatively microscopic. So this might
be a single log that describes the thing
that went wrong, the root cause of the
incident. And you know if you're lucky
after a few hours of everybody
frantically searching the incident gets
resolved and you know everybody can go
back to work that is until the next
production incident comes and the cycle
repeats itself. So this is a very
familiar situation to me unfortunately
it may be a very similar situation to
all of you but things have changed for
digital ocean. So
what traversal has been able to do for
digital ocean is make their mission
critical infrastructure far more
resilient. So you'll see here that uh
meanantime to resolution uh mtr has
reduced pretty dramatically for digital
ocean. We've measured that about 40%
reduction and the amount of time that it
takes to find and resolve production
incidents. And all of these minutes mean
a lot of pain for a engineer that's
that's now been removed and also
thousands of dollars for each minute. So
now I'll be able to show you how this
works.
So in the world post traversal rather
than this frantic search going on all
the time when an instant kicks off the
traversal AI the ambient traversal AI
begins its investigation. And the thing
that it begins its investigation with is
the same little bit of context that
engineers get when the incident starts.
And given the small amount of context,
traversal AI orchestrates a swarm of
expert AI sRes to sift through pabytes
of observability data all in parallel.
And so what was done previously manually
is done exhaustively and automatically.
And then after about five minutes,
traversal comes back to the users right
where they are in the incident slack
channel and tells them what happened. So
here you can see that uh traversal
identified an issue. There was a
deployment that introduced changes a
cascade of issues throughout the entire
system. And when engineers see this,
they can roll it back. They can move on
and and get back to their good work. And
you'll note here that uh traversal the
engineers of digital ocean noted that
this was this was the thing that solved
the issue. This was the correct finding.
And this is happening all the time.
Engineers that want to dive in further
can look in the traversal UI where you
have a wealth of information that
traversal unears uh describing what
happened with the incident. It cites
relevant observability data just like
any good engineer would. It gives you
confidence levels for the potential root
cause candidates. It explains its
reasoning. And if you want to dive in
even further, traversal allows you to
interact with an uh AI generated impact
map. And you can even ask follow-up
questions to traversal to describe to
ask questions like how does this
incident impact the part of the stack
that I care the most about? And this
entire experience is exactly the kind of
thing that I was dying for in my
previous roles and so excited to share
that it's now a reality.
So thank you. Uh so but this is not just
happening for digital ocean. We're
working across a very heterogeneous
group of uh enterprise environments. Uh
so you'll see here the thing that I want
you to focus on here is that we're
talking to basically every obser obser
observability tool out there and we're
talking to them on a massive scale.
We're talking trillions of logs. So yes,
it's an AI agents problem and I I like
thinking about the AI agents problem,
but in reality this is just as much an
AI infrastructure problem.
Furthermore, the problem that we're
solving here is one where we have a
massive set of data and we're looking
for this small piece of information
that's telling you everything that you
need to know. This is sort of a needle
in the haststack problem. And we're
focused right now on observability. But
there are plenty of other domains where
there are s similar principles that can
be applied in my experience that when
you're doing network observability,
you're working on cyber security, you
find similar patterns here that I hope
that you all in your respective domains
can take from this that these strategies
of exhaustive search and swarms of
agents can be applied in this in these
domains as well.
Uh not only is this an amazing problem
to work on, frankly, we've assembled an
amazing group of people to do it. Uh
we've got AI researchers from the top AI
labs in the world that that are pushing
the limits of what AI what AI can do. We
have people from top dev tools companies
who know what it takes to build a tool
that developers love to use. We have
fantastic AI product engineers who know
who know how to make delightful AI
products. And of course, we've got high
frequency quant finance traders who can
deal with pain and know what the pain of
production downtime actually means.
But I think what's uh most special about
the traversal team is not necessarily
the skills that that that we bring to
the table, but you know, it's it's
really unusual. It's really rare to be
able to find a group of people that
aren't really all out there for
themselves. And everybody's working for
the betterment of each other. And we
have a lot of fun coming into work and
everybody loves showing up to the
office. And this is what makes Reversal,
in my opinion, an amazing place to work.
And so if the team or the problem sounds
interesting to you, please uh scan the
QR code, look at one of these websites
and uh help us try to create this
picture of me that we have right here
for all all the engineers in the world.
Thank you very much.